[Music]
[Applause]
drinking coffee right now yeah welcome
back to Memphis break room one of us has
six espresso shots uh heading down the
hatch you'll be the judge of that
whoever's eyeballs pop out by the end of
the show uh welcome back to the break
room uh our daily nerdy news show keeps
you updated on all the stuff you need to
know
um today on our show I I trailed off a
little bit there at the end of the news
you're not on the coffee yeah no I need
the suspension on today's show Kang is a
sad boy oh we'll be talking Modoc of
course also the Oscars got it right uh
and they can't stop renaming the Agatha
Harkness show uh there might be we're
gonna try to get to some The Last of Us
news uh we got all kinds of interesting
this is actually a pretty full news day
so we're really excited to get into it
today with me to do that I've got
Brandon Barrick that's right I need the
battery Tess
okay uh we've got Jessica Clemens uh
don't make out with me if you have fungi
in your mouth it's gross yes uh Tommy
Bechtel
we're ready
jump scares and I'm Zach Huddleston
we're all thrilled to be here
um oh let's let's jump right into it
with the headlines there it is oh baby
okay our first couple headlines there's
a lot of Ant-Man the watch quantumania
news coming out uh some fun interviews
some new photos all kinds of stuff so
we're gonna jump into that Jeff loveness
the writer of the film close personal
friend of Tommy Bechtel I told sfx
magazine that some of his favorite
moments in the upcoming Ant-Man the WASP
uh quantumania come from Modoc our
favorite big head villain I'll just say
he was inspired by Kevin Klein in A Fish
Called Wanda and Frank Grimes in Old
Simpsons episode oh yeah so we're gonna
stop and talk about both these
references okay Jessica and I both big
fans of A Fish Called Wanda if you ever
watch that it's like a maybe mid 80s uh
kind of crime comedy uh Jamie Lee Curtis
in the news right now I mean everything
everywhere
did she get nominated yeah
[Music]
um well she's the the star of of this
which was back when she was kind of in
her uh sex symbol Heyday uh in the 80s
Uh Kevin Klein John Cleese and Kevin
Klein in this plays like a criminal uh
with a real fun mustache and he is
incredibly horny uh he's like very
ravenous after Jamie Lee Curtis and is
kind of like very dastardly always kind
of pulling off crimes and stuff like
that there's this horrible scene in it
where when he has sex and he gets off
his eyes cross and he falls back and
it's just very cartoon it's it's so it's
a big it's a big character it's a very
like literal it's very statistic yeah
very like literal mustache twirling so
it's interesting to hear that like Modoc
was inspired by that performance and if
you guys are looking to watch A Fish
Called Wanda it's actually screaming on
fuzzy right now what's fuzzy that's my
new streaming service uh we play classic
movies and furry porn yeah uh 50 50
split which and you can get 50 off with
hashtag smiling raccoon uh in our promo
box
um oh and then and then the second
references makes Frank Grimes a very
famous kind of early to mid-season uh
Simpsons episode and then a follow-up
where the son of Frank's trying to kill
him it's so interesting to have Frank
Grimes on Fish Called Wanda they're
weird really they're not necessarily the
same but can you remind us of the
friends who's like a guy who comes to
work at the nuclear plant with uh Homer
Simpson and points out everything in the
audience should already point out that
this man has everything he's an oaf he
does nothing right but he's he's gone to
space he's yeah he has a full family
Grimes has nothing he's always so put
down and he hates Homer and Homer has
nothing against this guy and spoiler he
dies he grabs
and like Homer is like
the Legacy lives on that Homer was like
his good friend but Grimes hated him
yeah and so both these characters that
he's referencing are like kind of bitter
yeah jealous angry kind of characters
which kind of makes sense if the I mean
in the Modoc character in general Who
Tommy knows a lot about him he made a
great video that's out on our Channel
kind of explaining uh Modoc
um but also if we think that you know it
hasn't officially been confirmed but
that uh Corey stalls Darren cross from
the first Ant-Man movie is going to be
kind of transformed into Modoc that
maybe he is kind of bitter angry
resentful maybe towards the Pim Clan
right particularly Scotland yeah kind of
like Hank Pym anointed the new Ant-Man
instead you know where like Darren cross
I think felt like maybe he should have
been the new Ant-Man or should have
carried on the Pim mantle so I I could
totally see it being like like Scott
Lang being the Homer Simpson in this
analogy oh so Dan Cross was there the
influence of cross particles that's
right he wasn't in his right mind okay
does he deserve to get particles make
everybody crazy no no well the uh pin
particles does too that's part of like
the helmet design is to help protect
your head over time too much too much uh
um shrinking and growing can mess your
brain up I think uh saying that it's
close to Kevin Klein's character in A
Fish Called Wanda and also the frame
Grimes is truly just leading to the fact
that he's gonna betray
um Kang or he's gonna work alongside I
don't think he's gonna fully work
alongside Scott but he's gonna be like
yeah this guy is mean to me all the time
what am I doing and that's how he's
going to get out of there interesting
interest because we've been talking
about right like they've purposely only
showed us the tiniest glimpses of this
characteristic movie so it's coming out
in a couple weeks right like Corey still
has not been doing press like they're
not really featuring him in any of the
promo so like it's a little bit of a
mystery what role Modoc is going to play
in this movie Brandon has a theory uh I
think he's gonna be the comedic relief
of this movie absolutely like all the
length stuff will be serious all the Pim
stuff will be serious do you not think
he's like the community so sad though
because he's still daring cross who was
like I am also a genius I'm also smart I
just got put in here by accident yeah
yeah he deserves it and then in the
comic books like Jaren cross goes on to
become like a villain because of his own
hubris and experimenting with stuff he
physically Alters his body it would be
interesting if it gets out of the
quantorama of this movie and he's back
in the real world either as Modoc or as
his normal human self again I don't know
I don't know uh that'd be really
interesting and then like yeah we were
kind of we've already speculated about
this like the trailer the way we see
Modoc in that one shot where everybody's
kind of walking in a line makes you you
know one might assume OS Modoc a king
henchman yeah right he's a lieutenant in
the Kang Army another a lesser Baddie
he's a Kingsman yes I'm trying to think
of uh um razor Fist from Shang Chi or
something like that he's gonna be more
of like an assistant I think he's gonna
treat him like a little butt yeah
um his shiny kind of attack does look
very Kang
in this movie I mean loving this said it
in this interview but when they call it
again but we haven't we haven't seen
that language used are they going to
call him Darren Cross or they're going
to call them Modoc uh tell me what does
Modoc stand for in the comics uh men
only do action that's not all right no
no no mechanical organism designed no
only for killing right interesting now
do we think they could also play with
that yeah and in the comic sometimes it
means other stuff but like a man only
died after killing
huh
uh Mike modak the Buffalo Bills reporter
R.I.P Buffalo Bills I I I think Modoc
will be fed I think it will stand with
something completely different
interesting and Dan will be like stop
calling me low down or he'll give
himself that name and they're like
he said he's like you can call me Modoc
and then I'll go
well you need to retire the Marvel
Cinematic Universe Trope of like that
name is Goofy yeah like that's a a
device they've used a lot uh to some
success to great success to middling
success I think the most successful one
being in uh infinity War when like
doctor strange and Spider-Man meet and
he's like oh we're using our made-up
names I'm Spiderman but they love the
name joke in so many Marvel movies let's
put it to bed also Modoc is a great name
it's a good name it's both an acronym
and we haven't had a lot of that other
other than maybe Ultron or something
like that right and um it sounds cool
I've yeah I'm I'm with you I agree it
sounds cool enough like referencing how
corny this stuff all is we're buying
into men and women in Spandex and capes
flying around that are actually standing
in front of like a a volume or blue
screen going like
how dare you bless you Elizabeth Olsen
you're doing a lot of work out there uh
sorry we didn't even finish the Jeff
lovelands quote about his inspiration
for Modoc uh yeah he says this really
put upon selfish entitled but then also
deeply sad insecure man who knows that
he got his uh [__] deal don't demonetize
this in life and is trying to make the
best of you you gotta shoot deal his ego
will crumble the second he's challenged
but then also like Kevin Klein and Fish
Called Wanda he's pretty good at killing
people the thing is wasn't good at
killing people
it was very obvious with that gun
um yeah but he uh Levin has mentioned
that like this was kind of the first
thing they figured out about this movie
yeah which is interesting like he's been
there from the beginning it wasn't like
oh we need a second bad guy and somebody
throws that out like no they knew from
the jump what's your take how we how we
land in this Ant-Man plane what
start there and you go from there uh
loveness also expanded on what we will
see from Kang going forward said Kang is
a top tier A-list Avengers villain
that's right uh he's almost this
infinite Thanos no what a fun term that
is an infinite Thanos uh I think we're
setting things up for a pretty Dynamic
story as I'm building two Avengers I
want it to feel like a generational
struggle well that's interesting in this
movie right because we're gonna have
multiple we're gonna have three
generations of characters yes uh phase
four felt like the birth of new
characters you're giving everyone a
little bit of a breath you're broadening
out the universe you have fun Disney
Plus shows that are elevating characters
and now I think it's time to put the
pedal to the gas again and really take
all these new characters that we like
and throw them into the fire Kang's also
a very lonely character we're going to
be seeing a lot of him in a lot of
different ways going forward but I
really wanted to introduce the humanity
and even the vulnerability of this
character before he gets to such
apocalyptic Avenger scale Heights
stunning this makes it sound like this
King doesn't die yeah it made it feel
like this King has feelings and after
seeing that American History X stomped
to the face that he gave Ant-Man I
disagree with that I don't think he does
I hear that this king is testing highest
amongst all villains
possible impossible well they say that
everything yeah is he gonna uh the the
the tier of order is gonna change
power yeah
also our our favorite uh MCU Muscle Man
Jonathan Majors uh has been given quotes
also he's got a film that's apparently
blown up at Sundance magazine dreams
because they play a pilot in this movie
that front is not lacking it's packing
what you ever seen bodybuilders and
they're wearing their little bikini
briefs and you're like what is that
little bunny yeah we can't we can't go
this way
no all right all right look it up he
said mushrooms
so done in the majors uh the actor
portraying King is uh doing a bunch of
interviews he he told deadline that his
Inspirations for the villain were
Alexander the Great Genghis Khan Julius
Caesar well that's a pretty impressive
huh what a lineup a lineup there uh no
no love for Ivan the Terrible come on
oh no he went on to say you're smart
watch watch out how smart I am you can
look at Robert Downey Jr's Iron Man
that's the superhero of superheroes in
order to be the super villain of super
villains how do I counteract that in the
Zeitgeist oh wow he's into this
character he loves it I'm so excited we
get planned so much John do we have an
image of Jonathan majors in his bikini
briefs proposing as a muscle man
no no text it to me computer isolate
image
um so uh that's great and I mean again
that's what we want out of our you know
actually playing major characters in
amcu they're taking very seriously
putting a ton of thought into it he so
far and maybe tell me if I'm wrong I
think he's the one that's most excited
to be playing this villain I'm so into
it and he's so smart and I think he's
playing this character so well already
yeah so I'm so excited and you can see
why like Kevin feige and the Brain
Twisted Marvel they could have picked
anybody to play Kang right John and the
majors had done some cool stuff but he
wasn't a huge name they probably could
have got bigger names to play this
character you know they met with this
guy and they're like wow he really wants
this he's gonna do a great job I think
it's a great blueprint get great actors
that want to play these ridiculous and I
mean that in a good way characters like
yeah he's like you know they're not
we're not we're not doing Jane Austen no
novels okay time traveling get that feel
with Thanos played by what's his name
I think he got there eventually by by
once the movie was all about him the
other movies that sorry I cut you off
but the other to answer your question
the other movie is that featured Thanos
seemed very kind of like
I don't know it seemed like he was he
showed up for a joke yeah he's a
boogeyman yeah he's off screen kind of
movie right yeah I also think they're
like digital face yeah always be like a
weird yeah
the way of water I believe all of his
blue face to wear like a foam big suit
yeah it has like Jonathan Majors because
it's coming crazy he gets to wear the
costume he's making sitting choices on
chairs
speaking of Avatar though Jessica how
about those Oscar nominations oh we're
gonna get to that in one second we're
gonna get to the set all right lastly
is like I didn't know you guys were
filming oh damn oh you caught me in a
vulnerable moment this is how I sit by
the pool all the time yeah I'm always
sitting with my in the Playboy stance uh
we we also got we got another image uh
from quantumania real quick we're gonna
pull up oh yeah oh okay we got Hank and
Janet and they're in their deep uh
Quantum realm outfits here jadorowski's
Dune or whatever it's giving Tatooine
Jabba's pleasure barred Chic it's
serving I mean those those do look like
some folks working in but two yeah
galaxies
we want to note the weird effect on the
edge of the frame here yeah uh it
doesn't it's not at the bottom of the
picture it's just on the side and we
don't know if this is something like
Marvel did just with this image to
release it like maybe they wanted to
blur out some things on the side if this
is Hank and Janet kind of walking
through some kind of weird portal
um we don't know we couldn't find the
source of this image that jazz I hope I
think it's hope that's what he meant I
meant oh wait no no that was Janet Van
Dyne that was that's Jana dude
Michael Douglas looks like Bradley
Whitford in that photo by the way this
is not for me this was from a totally
different movie this was just when they
went to Star Wars speaking of Star Wars
Galaxy a yeah Oscar nominations they're
announcing everything everywhere all at
once snag nominations for 11 of the 24
first nomination including Jamie Lee
Curtis this is insane this is insane
okay either way top gun Maverick also
managed to snag a best picture spot
which I was I knew yeah all of us at
that screening walked away going this is
the best movie ever made and and plus
side and Marvel news black panther were
kind of forever picked up uh Noms for
best supporting actress best costume
design best original song best makeup
and hair styling and best VFX which is a
lot the Batman on the other hand was one
of the other superhero movies to grab
some other Noms with three for VFX sound
makeup and hair styling a lot of people
unhappy cinematography nowadays yeah I
will I genuinely thought that Batman
would have got a little bit more there
was a I think for me personally uh best
year for the Academy Awards for me when
I say that because I wanted everything
everywhere all at once yeah so many
nominations I wanted them to be so
respected I wanted it's high regard it's
great art great job and they did it yeah
and obviously we were all blown away by
that Angela Bassett performance yeah
forever though she gets multiple I mean
her U.N speech when she's uh chewing out
akoye right like just some great great
moments and uh spoiler alert if you
haven't seen that movie it came out two
months ago I mean she gets a great death
scene even you know like yeah yeah are
you surprised that it was
from that film specifically been like a
koi could have been Nikia it could have
been the well I mean they might have I
don't know what their campaign was but a
lot of times you know with everything
everywhere all at once right you have
Jamie Lee Curtis and also Stephanie Sue
both nominated for supporting actress
and like a lot of times you have two
people from the same movie what's the
Vogue Marvel might have been like if
this is our best chance to get like they
are she already won a Golden Globe yeah
for this role this is our best chance to
finally get a nomination for acting
maybe we put it all in is also the
biggest actor in that film
now and she's For Better or Worse done
with the MCU yeah I mean they could
bring her in as a flashback as a ghost
or as a variant but for the most part
this is probably her last turn as Queen
ravinda is Black Panther leading for
Marvel for the Academy Awards yeah I
mean because it black panther one three
the the the first one yeah it's
nominated for five this year did we say
yeah a lot of the art uh categories yeah
I'm sorry no go ahead I would just say
just my my litmus test and all always
before Oscar of like what what movies
are promoting what is just driving
around because we see you know living in
La uh even though our office is in
Canada I I do my weekends back in L.A
with my wives and children's uh and I
and I drive around in in the exclusively
on the Black Panther poster they're uh
Angela Bassett had her own yes black
panther small font Angela Bassett yeah
like and it was like a star story of
Lost and whatever and a story of Lost
and family or something like that that
were specific four best actress for your
consideration Angela Bassett I think the
mcu's point is like we gotta like DC has
now what two two best two best uh Ledger
and Joaquin Phoenix both were playing
the Joker the metal it's a contest and
they won for most uh oh yeah exactly
sure worthy moment yeah
that's right they got two in there flash
goes Super Flash yeah go and the go box
do they do they win Oscars for that or
other statues
they don't win a statue yeah but every
other Oscar nominee that's like when I
was in winners they know it's a little
bit in 2003 I was nominated most crave
worthy by the five game of sorority so
uh and I picked up that award and a
little trophy if you know what I'm
saying uh
but no so I think that this is the mcu's
they're like we're getting one this year
they're putting it on I think it's like
yeah and I think a great to bet on
Angela always better Ambassador this is
our first nomination because she did she
win for Ike and uh um for uh What's Love
Got to Do with it I know she was
nominated I don't know if she won or not
but um yeah
long uh procedures yeah
and you know marvel films usually are
nominated in the VFX and some of the
other like technical categories but I
love this now if we were to go back
maybe I mean the last year right we had
a couple other films can we think of any
other Marvel actors in love and thunder
Multiverse Madness that deserves maybe a
look
um you go first okay I'm gonna say it's
always really tough you know it's hard
to say what what's a better performance
like a couple of guys putzing around on
a real Island in Ireland with all the
real stuff shots fired at banshees of
insurance yeah or uh like Elizabeth
Olsen being on a green screen on wires
half of her costume being digitally made
doing this stuff like and being
emotional and impactful I don't know you
know it's the Oscars are very subjective
and you know well also I would nominate
us but also for what she's done with the
character I wouldn't because it's only
for Multiverse Madness and I don't think
she did as great numbers away from
Madness as she did for one division
exactly
but I think it's a great point also
though even if you think about like
cultural impact how many more millions
of people saw her portray Scarlet witch
in that film then saw combined all of
the actresses nominated right it's not
tar then saw uh you know um to Leslie
which we were talking about which is a
movie that has made a total of twenty
seven thousand dollars I think at the
box office right
um those people campaign
Stephen Root a graduate of the
University of Florida go Gators I have a
question so so you I want to answer your
question because I thought it was a good
question what Marvel movies would you
have considered acting contenders I
think to me the problem is the one
performance that I would consider is the
movies named after him but he's a
supporting actor in it and that's
Captain America in Civil War I would
have thought that portrayal having to
deal with you know Bucky being clearly
because Tony Stark being completely
reasonable wanting to kill Bucky after
finding out he killed his grants lie
Tony Stark kept Chris Evans character
Captain America although that
performance would be worthy of a
supporting actor nomination but you
can't nominate Captain America for a
supporting actor in a movie that's it
that's a good point yeah if I think and
this is
someone come for me
um I think I would give mine to Aunt May
uh as supporting because that's
technically less would have been uh
but I also think that we need to start
making a category
no we need to make a category for like
choreography because then that's when we
would be given that award to like shanxi
and we'd be acknowledging a lot of the
action and superhero films that don't
really get that notice
for like stunt work and stuff but that's
like creative yeah it's not creative
arts or whatever
and people have talked about a lot a lot
like you know how
um yeah you know there are certain types
of acting that the Oscars over represent
right real cry big emotional dramatic
acting whereas like comedic acting is
never rewarded
has ever gave some crazy horse
and like you know action big budget
fancy stuff I mean one of the big steps
people are talking about Mr Tom Cruise
right not getting enough for Top Gun
management flying a plane he was
literally
they said he shouldn't be in there there
are a hundred thousand people in Los
Angeles right now that can cry on
command there are like four that could
fly a plane like that okay and run with
those blades look whether you break his
ankles and keep running I know whether
you agree with the Oscars or not we all
know who we're a nominating for best
supporting dinner and that's Factor yeah
what a transition factor is here to help
you save time and energy with factors
ready to eat meals delivered straight to
your door you can even have to go to the
grocery store get factor and not only
skip the trip to that stupid grocery
store but skip the chopping the prepping
the cleaning the complaining from your
partner because you're taking too long
just shut up I'm trying to make you
dinner stop yelling at me wait a minute
it's Factor's fresh never frozen meals
already in just two minutes so all you
have to do is heat and enjoy Factor has
meals that are keto calorie smart vegan
and veggie and full of protein prepared
by chefs and approved by dietitians each
meal has all the ingredients you need to
feel satisfied all day long Factor meals
have all the ingredients you want too
nothing you don't no no weird I wouldn't
pop it and say as somebody who has
infected meals and once you get some
more like they not only they taste
really good and when you read the back
you're like how is there less calories
than what I just ate that was delicious
than like a bologna sandwich I sometimes
make you know what I mean they're like
very tasty very filling and like pretty
like good for you I'm always surprised
when I eat those yeah they're really
good a lot of us see at the office use
them they're great to like pop in and
just heat up quick and get on the go uh
it's like clean eating without all the
hassle because again the ingredients are
fresh good ingredients simply choose
your meals and enjoy fresh flavor-packed
meals delivered to your door again ready
in just two minutes it's very easy
achieve and maintain your goals this
year with Factor get America's number
one ready to eat meal kit and start
saving time eating well and living your
best year ever head to factormeals.com
break room 60 and use code break room 60
to get 60 off your first box that's code
break room 60 at factormeels.com break
room 60 to get 60 and again we just want
to quickly shout out because you've
probably heard us talk about hellofresh
on this show owned by the same company
basically if you like doing a little
cooking go hella fresh if you're like I
don't want to do any cooking besides
popping something in the microwave go
faster they're both real tasty and I
want to just throw one more hat in the
ring uh you I've said that I have goals
this year every roller coaster at
Universal not kicked out and uh wearing
a pharity classic shirt uh that doesn't
come in the size I can wear yet I'm
doing Factor February oh I'm signing I'm
doing a factory February I'm also doing
dry January or dry February why less
days let's stay smart oh they got to be
dry dry months only got to be dry for 28
and guess what black history
I'm honoring I'm honoring my fellow
black kings my monitoring my commitment
to weight loss and and I want to say
this just because it's dry February
doesn't mean my sheets stay dry okay I
make no commitment to not wetting the
beds
I will continue to wet the bed randomly
to keep my maid on her toes
uh note that Tommy only made this
commitment after he knew the bills would
not be in the Superbowl
February previously oh my gosh uh well
uh despite that breaking news
my goodness sploosh uh we got some more
headlines for you folks out there
I hope so too filming has wrapped for
the upcoming Disney plus uh Star Wars
series Skeleton Crew Disney star for you
International folks out there uh the
series is set to Premiere later this
year we'll see if they push that back
they haven't yeah
and this would in theory right be the
third series we'd get to share after
Amanda Warren starts in March we think
we're getting Ahsoka maybe in the summer
yeah and then maybe this should be the
fall winter or something in the middle
of the bad batch right now if you count
the bad batch and I don't know if
there's more tales of the Jedi this year
all right I mean we're doing more I
don't know who knows uh we also got a
new image of the Agatha coven of chaos
slate the little clacker they use uh
when they're filming stuff this one says
my pretty uh referencing the Wicked
Witch of the West from Wizard of Oz now
this is not a new name of the show it's
something they do on set they'll be
cheeky can you go back to it really
quick uh you could see like the name of
the director Jack Schaefer directing
this episode and then Caleb Heyman is
the camera operator they'll do this
sometime on set this has nothing to do
with like getting another show it's not
changing am I pretty or anything it's
still so insane how in-depth they even
do for the little art for the clap yeah
like that's so fun time to point out
like one of the Star Wars movies was
called red Solo uh red cup was the
working title of uh of solo for a while
a lot of the times these Productions
have working titles so that when they
have to put signs up around town people
don't know what they're famously Blue
Harvest the Bob's Burgers movie was Jeff
Jazzy jazz hands and it was so hard to
say and I remember being like why did we
do this return the Jedi was like blue
forest or something like that and we
wanted to if we wanted to just play a
little uh conspiracy corner here right
like I think Tommy you pointed out or
somebody pointed out right my pretty the
famous line that the witch says in
Wizard of Oz what if much like how One
Division had different kind of TV show
themes it was the Full House episode
there was the uh Leave it to Beaver
episode whatever the generational yeah
what if this like each episode is kind
of themed around different famous
witches they do American Horror Story
why not the craft who wouldn't love to
see all those chokers and Eric Andre and
his Joker and black nail polish some
things they just dressed up as a craft I
don't remember what it was
um I don't remember I dressed up as a
craft single a craft single single and
ready to Jingle uh next headline Adult
Swim has ended its relationship with
co-creator Justin Roiland Rick and Morty
will continue without him and season
seven is currently in production uh
Adult Swim put out uh this announcement
of this on
um Twitter Instagram today so this is
kind of breaking news right before we
went live if you want to know what the
story is look it up I don't want to get
into it yeah you can Google that no uh
this obviously has a big ramification on
the show yeah he's a co-creator and a
producer of the show but he voices
voices main characters
no Hulu hasn't anything yet but uh I
think the show's just gonna be called
and moving forward right I don't know
Rick I don't know what they'll do real
quick off of that uh Downer note I just
want to shout out the shirt I'm wearing
uh because I forgot to plug it earlier
left field speaking of which we got a
new shirt coming out oh my
God this is a great reference Tommy ah
so this is we actually this is the
newest shirt in the uh the
rockstarsmerch.com uh shop it's our
circles and arrows line yeah you see the
pattern of this is like our thumbnail
designs on our YouTube videos little
circles and arrows to the hidden details
you can get this button up shirt and uh
We've shown these off on the show this
is a sticker pack yeah these things come
off and you could take like a family
photo or your fridge or your
refrigerator whatever do a little signal
or circles and arrows make um you know
make your family photo look like a new
rock stars
details in your life yeah you can find
these and a bunch of other stuff new
Rockstar's merch
and don't forget to be careful putting
two circles and three dots next to each
other because that's how you get a
cootie shot oh I'm single people getting
vaccinated okay uh next headline Jason
Momoa told variety that he will quote
always be Aquaman you like it or not a
reference to his uh recent meeting with
DC heads uh James Gunn and Peter saffron
he said quote we've got a lot of good
things coming release Aquaman 2 please
YouTube's got immediately tweet it out
afterwards no we don't Jason said yes we
do well and that's my mom would be
Aquaman and put out his movie already
movie yeah in Iron Man 2. this movie
Yes I want Samoa
um MOA I want some some Mo of anyway
what Dennis fascinating if we've got a
lot of good things coming they could
have just been talking about Aquaman too
yeah right like sure or there's always
been there's been this speculation Jason
Momoa might play a different character
in the DC oh I don't care
let's go back to that a little bit later
yeah just put them out uh a new trailer
and poster for Harley Quinn a very
problematic Valentine Day special just
came out
what's their name uh Carl Ivy harlivy oh
this is my wife you want a Beyonce and
Jay-Z's kids maybe
this is an animated series that's still
on HBO Max one of the few that didn't
get cut off the channel uh it's really
great if you never checked it out it's
very funny I know it's really good I
don't know who does uh was it is it
Stephen tudik does uh
I was like who's Stephen I don't know
it's Alan tuna goes it's great The Joker
and tunic is a character yeah you guys
you guys have never seen my original
character Stephen tudik he's the one
keeping uh Tommy's bed sheets wet all
February hey he's the world's sweatiest
Detective
the second episode of The Last of Us
almost had a much darker opener we
learned oh uh accordingly because it's
I'm glad they went the musical number
yeah it's just gonna be a butthole
sorry
record uh that's a dark opening all
right according to the showrunners
episode two had quote a cult open where
we just like the camera is pushing on
this door and you just hear the sound
pounding coming from the basement oh boy
and then we cut and then later Tess
would tell the story of how she couldn't
kill her son basically if you know the
character test on the show she uh they
wound up cutting that from the opening
and it's maybe part of her Baxter will
get into I don't know but a very dark
kind of okay it Harkens back to a little
bit of uh was it herschel's farm and
Walking Dead yeah
in the barn uh and so she yeah the the
story they were going to tell is like
her backstory she had this family uh her
husband and son get infected she kills
her husband can't bring herself and
kills his son
in theory that person is still in the
basement to this are we eternally alive
inside of the basement it could come
back yes but do you think it was also
just made because it was like
giving her more of this backstory and
then killing her immediately would have
been just like what's the point yeah why
would we do this why would we make dip
die we don't learn much about tests in
the in the game and they we've already
learned a little bit more about her in
the show right than we did in the game
but this was something that we're gonna
add in and they cut it out and you know
I also want to just point out uh
pounding and coming from the basement
was the first Stephen two dicks okay
origin story novel let's move on
real quick before we move on last of us
we are loving this uh Brandon Jessica
and I've been doing a great job uh
yesterday on the uh break room after
show for that series we're really
excited about going forward yeah we're
covering the series uh we're uh break
room's dark on Mondays we're on Sundays
doing the after show for the series if
you've missed us on Mondays that's where
we are come watch us on Sundays and
watch The Last of Us it like double this
viewership to episode two uh popular
show good uh makes me hungry for
mushrooms we've got seven more weeks of
it yeah uh in the first season I I also
think I just want to put this out here
because you know we are these on record
they they are about a day later after we
shoot them we should do a Redemption
where we eat mushroom foods not mushroom
psychedelics but like yeah different
flavored things yeah mushroom caps yeah
we should eat Jonathan Majors mushroom
cake what if we do we do tasty we do
tasty trippy and toxic yes random
mushrooms we have to it's like Russian
Roulette yeah you don't know what you're
getting I want to see if if you can
blindfold and identify a wood ear from
uh Portobello oh I like the chicken of
the woods hey Hen of the Woods there's
there's a there's a mushroom called
chicken in the woods
oh okay you got it what's it called two
dicks it's time for mandatory fun yeah
that's right oh I should say no what's
better than two dick three dick ah play
the graphic again
[Laughter]
hey hey hey you think three days is a
lot when we played dicks for play the
graphics some more
hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
keep it positive keep it wait okay
at night play Jonathan Majors no no
oh he's not hard to pull up oh no he
photoshopped his
face
I think it's in the pool they probably
had to turn it down stuck behind the
back of the shorts into the pool like a
little
periscope foreign
anyway Jimmy Gunn has once again teased
the entertainment industry like he
always does this time saying when it
comes to the casting of the DCU we've
had hundreds of roles to cast and as
I've always done some will be brand new
faces some will be actors I've worked
with before and some will be actors you
know who I've never worked with so
basically anyone who's ever tried to act
okay in the game what matters most is
the actor fits the role and they're easy
to work with this is a crazy thing I've
never told you guys wow okay I'm
actually related to James Scott what
what so I think that would have come up
at some point yeah you never brought it
up I'm his cousin oh my real name is
Tommy Gun Tommy Gun Google it Google
Tommy goes nepotism please don't Google
Tommy Gun destroys and then blank blank
blank and let it fill in the blanks yeah
no uh do not tell these kids to do that
I'm not telling any kids to do that
you know what I'm saying just the
naughty just the naughty guys and gals
out there now
I actually work as his casting assistant
part-time on this show you guys know I
work about 90 hours a week yeah yeah I
spend the other 30 uh working with Jimmy
on his projects uh casting
and I know all three of you are
wonderful hosts wonderful personality
yeah but I also go through the three of
you
are pretty aggressive thespians so uh I
would say you're some of the most
aggressive thespians I've ever seen in
my life you're the one that's worked the
most as an actor you know what though
that's because I got the face and body
for it you guys got the talent and
that's why I'm giving you a chance I've
got sides from Jimmy oh for the new
projects how did you get these I'm just
causing Tommy Gunn Google tommy gun
images
Google Tommy Gun Unleashed uh
uh Tommy Gun covers uh for my cover
songs now Tommy Gun mushroom soup might
work as well uh
we're gonna run this like a real
audition room I want all three of you to
leave I'm gonna call you in one of the
times okay okay okay all right uh we're
running a little behind guys sorry sorry
we just saw all of the Baldwin brothers
even the ones being charged with murder
all right uh Zach Huddleston that's me
Zach Huddleston yes uh hey uh Jimmy uh
go ahead I haven't seen anywhere oh okay
right here
we've got you reading for Superman uh
Superman Origins movie Jimmy's looking
for a young face a fresh face to play
Superman so I might be I might be older
than uh okay thank you we we just I'm
gonna read I'll be Jimmy Olsen you'll
obviously be Superman okay uh and I
should be I should be like feeling
careful I should be feeling Ralph I
should be feeling make it your own okay
I think really we're looking for
something we're looking to turn Superman
on his head here oh okay interior Daily
Planet day
Jimmy Olsen is carrying a tray of coffee
when he runs smack dab into a large
broad-shouldered new guy hey watch it
new guy what's your name my name is Cal
I I mean Superman I mean Clark Clark
can't well watch where you're going poor
Kent by the way Perry white is on a
rampage so I'd steer clear of him oh if
I see him I'll walk the other way
faster than a speeding bullet
and watch out for those three
muscle-bound pro wrestlers that are
walking around they're pretty drunk oh
I'll always watch out for truth justice
and the American way oh well other than
that Wednesday we all meet up for
karaoke and Friday is our fun t-shirt
day sounds super the
man
I thought it was I thought it was part
of the script said Clark can't
I think that was uh
that was intentional get out of here
we'll be in touch okay thank you you
need a headshot or I don't need it no
we're all digital now we're green
right now we have a we have a file full
of them we'll never see that guy again
uh Jessica Clemens
Jessica Marie Clemens president
you guys can have a seat yeah
uh it's great to see you here it's great
to see you can I see your license I
don't have one I just want to verify
your 18. okay
you will be reading for the role of
Wonder Woman okay what's my motivation
uh you want a job in Hollywood so you'll
do anything
Superior invisible jet dusk Wonder Woman
is flying or invisible jet with Aquaman
in the passenger seat just dropped me
off over anything wet and I'll swim home
not yet Arthur there's something I need
to tell I need you to tell me I need the
truth even if you think it will hurt my
feelings Diana friends don't lie okay
did everyone hate the song I sang at the
Justice League Christmas party no not at
all it was rocking come on Artie I can
tell you're lying I'm serious I mean I
guess I would do anything for love but I
won't do that by Meatloaf is a pretty
long song and we only rented the machine
for two hours so it was pretty selfish
which is a pretty common thing hey sorry
art I put the lasso of Truth around you
and you you sung like a canary please
always tell me the truth we are friends
and the trust is a Bedrock of any great
friendship I forgive you for lying and
look forward to our future endeavors
I think we're good okay okay great we'll
be in touch oh very good hey actually do
you have a head shot um
in my back pocket okay great
okay last we have Brandon Barrick
Brandon Barrick
Brandon bear oh God
I will shave my head oh wow okay well I
don't know that we're gonna need that
okay this is uh this is where you'll be
reading for Bruce Wayne oh okay we're
not sure if we're gonna double cast
Bruce Wayne and Batman with the same
actor uh okay well we'll just see how
the read goes I'll be playing Alpha so I
could might only be Bruce Wayne or
Batman that's right okay we'll see how
the read goes but we're very
I'll just put it this way Jimmy's a fan
oh okay all right but don't let that go
to your head right all right okay
interior Wayne Manor Knight
Alfred brings Bruce's evening tea Bruce
takes a sip then takes a longer sip can
I use this sure yeah absolutely
Alfred this tea there's something
different about it something not even
the world's greatest detective can
decipher
boy that's Joshua oh embarrassment I
picked up in the Royal Navy
it's it's hypnotic my whole body is
dancing on the inside maybe for once
this won't be
a dark night
boy
Master Warrior there's something else
about the tree oh
you tricked me
you little Joker that's right I replace
your sleepy time tea with smooth
movements laxative tea happy April Fools
Day
hahaha
[Laughter]
[Music]
oh
wow I didn't know we could improvise
that was great wow we actually are not
gonna need any further auditions you
need a headshot I don't
um
same chair Tommy you don't have anything
prepared or oh well this is a little
embarrassing oh I actually already
booked a roll oh yeah uh I booked a roll
I thought maybe if you guys wanted I
could you could do the monologues that
got me the part oh yeah
I'm playing the role of uh Jeff Parker
he's the next door neighbor to George
and Martha Kent uh
he's also Clark Kent's Little League I
don't know him from the comics
come on everybody
take a knee take any
ship into my backyard and his dad hasn't
paid for me to fill that hole yet he's
supposed to bring an earth mover
fill the hole back up
you killed six sheep with your ship
go buy a ship pay cheap those were cheap
cheap
secondary
every time I put you up to back you hit
the ball so goddamn far we can't find it
I want your dad to bring me a cup of
your piss on my doorstep
by Monday morning
Brandon I'm gonna taste that piss
and if I taste one ounce of steroids
you're off the team
thirdly some of you might have heard
that I've been indicted by the IRS for
tax evasion
but I want to let you know I'll never
give up on this team because one thing I
know about eight and under Little League
Baseball is you don't [__] quit on
your teammates
you don't quit we look each other in the
eye and we're all we got this is a long
scene we're all we got where was uh
Jason Darren Devin Dalton Candace Parker
Jagger Romero Stephen Christian Alex Ben
Calvin Jacob Christopher Nolan okay look
each other in the eyes all you got is
each other the next week we play
Penfield okay and I want to let you know
something about that that team is full
of anti semi my team is full of racist
and that team is full of former major
league baseball players that are
Benjamin buttoning back into babies
and when they die they die for good but
you guys
the average life expectancy of an
American man is 75 so you've got 67 more
years on this goddamn Planet except for
you Clark oh I got a feeling about you
there's something off about you and it
ain't super
man oh wow
I got I got two questions one where was
Jeff Parker on January 6th oh he was at
the Capitol
he was at Capital City guys Google Tommy
Gun destroyed Jeff Parker because oh
what a what a performance that was wow
wow so yeah you guys look out for me on
no a Superman origin
[Music]
why don't you need any more of our money
we'll always take your money oh we
definitely we still need money also
Corey Ken's really out there trying to
get us the hot stuff that's why the
super oh interesting wow the madranged
space out those we did a lot of them for
a while and we still love doing those
but we want to try to space them out my
ear nose and throat guy says between the
pills that I crush up and snort and the
hot sauce redemptions I will be able to
breathe swallow chew or blow out come on
within the next two years come on uh but
they'll probably be coming back soon
we're gonna try to sprinkle those in
thank you uh yeah uh there is a dog
under the table uh uh Jamie Riley uh for
fart sounds he sends in a Super Chat we
appreciate you Jimmy Ryan Brandon might
even break you off a free one no for
free
um
uh yeah again Corey can drilly asked if
anyone's watched Kaleidoscope on Netflix
no that's the uh Esposito kind of Choose
Your Own Adventure wow right it's more
that like it's uh the same time and
you're seeing different perspectives
like the last episode is the heist and
then all the other episodes you're just
gonna watch the white like they're all
colors right well you get them in a
random order I think they're giving
people randomly we need to watch that
thank you for uh reminding us uh to
check that out also I saw an excellent
trailer sorry for uh for all of you to
check out uh hello tomorrow on Apple TV
with Billy crudrum which like basically
like if like the 40s and 50s predictions
of the 60s and 70s actually came true
and they were like flying car it's all
very stylized like Jetsons but live
action and it's all about selling time
shares on the moon oh that's like a West
Anderson
thank you everybody for watching today
uh tune back in tomorrow we'll have we
have a lot more fun stuff uh scheduled
for this week
um and again catch up on last of us if
you haven't already Eric's breakdown of
episode two's up on the channel now so
check that out he's got a trailer uh the
trailer breakdown for the next episode
and I and I just heard from my cousin
Jimmy you guys are all getting callbacks
I have been I have however been fired
from my roles
turns out they found out where I was on
January I was at a Dairy Queen sucking
all the soft serve after hours no Tommy
uh Google's second off the song yeah uh
thank you all for watching so much uh
this this was entirely too much fun we
appreciate you being here for it
everybody keep it Gucci to moochi bye
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]